[Music]
so I'm gonna ask your Instagram
questions we're going to go right down
the list ready we're sitting on the set
of Shark Tank Season eleven being taped
right now
first question how long does it take to
actually tape a whole season well
basically we tape about 10 to 12 deals a
day and we work for about two to three
weeks in June two to three weeks in
September so basically three four five
six weeks depending on the season
because you never know how long a binge
is going to be so a couple of months to
work go into this it takes time to do it
right question number two do I invest my
own money or does the show have its
money all of this money is money when I
make an investment it's my personal cash
that's why I care about it so much I
care about these deals because it's my
cash don't miss this poster
that poster it has all six of the main
sharks even though any one time you
usually only have five starts under set
but that's the original cast right there
right from the beginning
barbar me
okay
imagine six sharks they'd eat you alive
okay
does anybody have a sharpie maybe I
could sign this nice card Oh
what a dick what an idiot like that such
a waste of money
a question how long's the average pitch
a great question
pitch is last from 20 minutes to an hour
and a half and they get edited down to
about seven or eight minutes it takes a
long time to do this so sometimes the
deal is very competitive
that's the once hour and a half long
sometimes nobody wants any of it 20
minutes happens just don't know they
walked in the door it's all random
what's the best part of filming an
episode getting a deal you love that's
always a great moment when you love
something and you win it is absolutely
fantastic
photobomb she's just jealous
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
my number one shark tape moneymaker was
the sale of plated to Albertsons for 300
million dollars there's never been a
bigger exit than that in Shark Tank
history that's a big question I get all
the time who's my favorite shark to sit
beside it's always the same answer I
allow that mr. wonderful guy he's
fantastic all right so now you start to
get an idea of how big this set is so
there's likes to sound actually it's the
stage over there
[Music]
an area where guests can watch the show
being made
morning
yeah so these are the guys that work on
doing a little social media so after
deal is done we've got teams that work
with the entrepreneurs to get all the
paperwork going the villages started and
everything else at all let's go look at
the donuts now this is what you wanted
to stay away from a lot of calories in
the air fresh fruit that's good
so scrambled eggs and maybe a little
veggie - this is vegetarian cauliflower
index is probably a breakfast
enchantments right there and that's it
you that is not bad food so you have
lots of options
cute one the green ones are vegetarian
and the ones are bacon is to stay away
from all these calories like getting in
feed about this why do I offer you our
LT deals I don't always do royalty deals
there's all kinds of structures I'm
actually the king of structures on Shark
Tank all the other sharks learn from me
now we're out to do some very poignant
did you get your money back faster I do
those but also convertible debentures
structured debt preference shares you
name it I do it I'm the financial one of
the most important things you can do in
life is invest in yourself and one great
way to do that is to subscribe to my
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that notification bell so you get the
latest updates of my data this is stuff
I don't put anywhere else I'm sharing
with you on my youtube channel you know
all the things that have helped me get
success in life it's a great place it's
a great resource and I want to help you
share share share pass it forward that's
what the mr. wonderful youtube channel
is all about subscribe to my channel you
know what happens you'll be dead to me
[Music]
[Music]